hi everyone i just wanted to apologize
for the occasional sort of audio crackle
you'll hear in this episode
it is very much embedded in troy's mic i
wasn't able to edit it out unfortunately
hopefully
it's not too bad uh to the show the
start of this is going to be really
weird for any audio listeners have fun
what that's not just like a dick pic
oh the angle is too low you're a titty
streamer now titty streamer hey
everybody yeah just make sure you're
liking but no plunging neckline today
i can make it plunging yeah we we need
to use you
as our click bait more often troy so you
could
sexualize yourself slightly more no
it'll be really helpful for the show
look look i think we all know if if this
thing was going to lean
on like sexual energy it's clearly
it's me right now yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely
no offense austin uh it's just mike oh
none take and i'm in agreement
you know i work at it that's that's all
it is yeah for what you have
i get it i get it you know it's the
haircut that did it for me too
i was like he was he was kind of good
looking before and then it was like get
that haircut it's like that's a snack
right there
i also saw someone share a screenshot
from the show a while ago and
like just comparatively mike it looks
like you've lost a bunch of weight
i have yeah and i guess i'd because i
see you regularly
the anxiety of doing this weekly i lose
i lose two pounds every time we do this
i am straight as a country robe but the
second that carrie decides that she's
just tired of you
it is yeah me and then austin on the
side and then and then alana gets to
officiate
the most horrid trifecta wedding ever oh
dj
weddings yeah dude on the side i am down
on this side it's like
it's your night tonight my fate could be
worse i guess
well that's a cold opening yeah
[Music]
and the fan fiction goes boom
[Laughter]
i am joined by troy baker who is a video
game actor austin wintry who is a video
game composer and mike bithell who is a
video game director
slash programmer we always have to say
that oh
point it look how easy i did that i did
that so easily
still is completely irrelevant i know i
know but i'm saying for me
i pointed my from my perspective
normally it's like super weird
i think i've been trying to do it with
my left hand or something i don't know
it's like boom boom boom
you know what i'm proud of you no it's
completely irrelevant but i'm 24.
everyone it's amazing great core motor
skills mad like it's just impressive
so there are like a million things to
talk about right now to the extent that
i wasn't sure what to talk about
um austin suggested some super good
topics and there is one that i wanted to
dive into straight away but i do also
want to talk about the nintendo leaks
i did explicitly promise you at the
start of the show last week that i would
talk to you about uh the mandalorian
emmys and then never return to it which
means i broke my promise i'm super sorry
i don't care about that anymore oh he's
moved on
wait wait wait the mandalorian emmys
nominations yeah it was nominated for
like every category it's
it's an insane sweep it's uh breaking
stuff but we're gonna
jump into uh uh the video game discourse
this week um the discourse we call it
which is specifically um i believe it
was a polygon article that was published
that was about uh how video games need
to go back to being black and
white yeah what was that article i i
think it was mainly a critique of troy's
performances from the article i read
right it's just the the use of the term
sludge
when he was talking about now they're
just gray sludges i'm like
no that is the
who is the writer i want to make sure
i'm not like just was it a he or she
i sadly don't know how to pronounce this
name it's from someone called
kihun chan and i
they perfect um
i in reading the article
i understand the position that they're
coming from but
i it's such a reductive
oversimplification of like
stories just need to be this i'm like
well that suits your taste
and this is the problem i mean i suppose
we could say it's discourse
but there's not really much of a
discourse when someone touts their
opinion
as objective fact and that's the problem
that i i
immediately had with the articles like
what are you talking about
it just it just it didn't for me it for
me it pinged
we better say something to lana i was
just going to say that's an interesting
point because um
that's often just the way that features
are written it is on
to inherently know that and i like i
actually do edit most of my editors to
be like
you need to write this like an opinion i
think i do do that
uh but that is the format the correct
format of writing a feature especially
if it's an argumentative essay style or
feature is to write it like it's a fact
and it's on the audience to know
this is an opinion because of course
it's an opinion rather than like leaving
a comment that's your opinion
man yeah so that's it is an interesting
one to talk about in that like i do get
frustrated when people write things as
fact even though it's their opinion
but you are also supposed to of course
you know that's their opinion
like you know that truth but it's also
is it not incumbent upon them to go
i feel this i find this this is my
opinion and then to state
the supporting evidence as fact you know
what i mean it's not again
you can't say the earth is flat and it's
it's it's
to me that interesting one because again
that's the way that i write
is an argumentative essay is you write a
sentence and then you back it up with a
source in the next sentence
um but generally the format of a feature
uh
you you do not have to write in my
opinion in
university they would consider that
clutter because they would be like why
are you telling me i know this is an
opinion piece it's an assumption of an
opinion
yeah um i mean i think that's i think
that's fair
um it it i mean at the end of the day
you could also just even if they are
asserting it as fact
it's easy to just sort of go down that
rabbit hole of saying
you know unless you unless you are
sort of empirically backing these claims
then it is your opinion irrespective of
what you label it
but that's what the thing is i do like
that our response to this to this
feature is to have a debate about
whether the features should be black and
white or grey
like we've kind of immediately got
matter meta
but the problem is that i found in the
article that article specific is that
there was not
immediate and forgive me if i'm
forgetting something and call it to
memory but there wasn't empirical
evidence to support it it just continued
to be
a subjective opinion to support
the subjective opinion you know what i
mean it wasn't like do you notice how
they did this and then there's this but
then there was
it's it's no objective opinions like it
just they feel
the characters feel sludgy and they
don't feel like they do anything it's
like
okay but back up your opinion with
objective fact as opposed to
i just feel this way chocolate is is
there a way is there a way of making
that argument objectively though like i
i mean
i have my own opinions on the article
but like can could could they
realistically have done that like it
feels like well i think i i think it's
all subjective
yeah my face just did so much
no is the answer is right no you cannot
actually
that's what i suspected to be honest
yeah however really
you what troy is asking for is again my
favorite style of writing what i ask for
from all of my editors
what i asked for at ign like as a
managing editor what i make people write
is the same thing as troy because it is
my preferred medium is an argumentative
essay which is
every sentence you write i need a source
from you
unless you say it's my opinion because
you're a [ __ ] journalist i'm not here
to read your opinion i am here
to have you get a lot of information
that i won't necessarily access and put
it together and present a piece like a
most recent edit that i did was someone
made a comment along the lines of the
minimum wage hasn't increased
in this amount of time and i was like
who the [ __ ] are you to say that like i
get that that might be common knowledge
to you and you think that that's
something you know but i need a source
for that information
uh an argumentative essay is for sure my
preferred medium but what this feature
actually is is an editorial and the way
that ign
gets around just like an editorial
opinion piece is by putting opinion in
the headline
polygon didn't do that it does make a
difference um you can't do it
objectively but you can do it in a way
that is
researched and less subjective which i
think is what troy is asking for which i
personally agree we should ask for more
of i agree and not only that it's it's
whether you put that
you know uh prerequisite or or whatever
at the top of it that says this is an
opinion
it's just poorly written that if you if
you want me to believe what you're
saying is a
fact or or at least is a is a
strong enough argument if they want to
convince you yeah and then come at me
with uh
with other thing than just your opinion
because i can't argue your opinion
um that that's just like
if someone were to say this it's like
okay well that's yeah i think chocolate
is gross
okay i can't argue that but if you go
did you know that what chocolate is made
of
actually negatively in fact impacts your
body
regardless of your system regardless of
your taste buds but chocolate
because it's made of this thing or
chocolate is healthy for you
that's your opinion but you can actually
back it up and say because of these
properties that chocolate has i can
support the fact
that this opinion is well founded and
what i didn't see in that article was
someone just going i just didn't like it
like that's not then they don't need to
return to to suit your taste
don't play the game for me so that's
funny because it gave me this flashback
to i remember
reading i i want to say this too long
but i do just want to count on i do
actually think this piece is well
written i do think this writer is a good
writer i do think that sentences are
like coherent and nicely written i don't
want to discredit them for that but i
also understand
your issue with basically this format in
general um sorry go ahead
it sounds like it's a more of an
editorial criticism troy's maybe
leveling rather than uh
yeah which i totally get right oh dude
sorry i'm not trying i just want to
hang on this just real quick let's go
around the circle
um i in austin we'll we'll
back this up hopefully as well i thrive
on discourse and even contentious
conversation
i love having my views my beliefs
child no you don't prove it how dare you
yes citation needed i i
i love it when someone presents
something especially when it's an
oppositional view and gives me the
opportunity to go oh [ __ ]
i never thought about that way let me
think about that do i really feel this
way or if i just always believe this to
be true
so i i actually love it when someone
does that
i don't feel this person did that and
they didn't even recite me specifically
even though they cited the game
so it's not like i have some bias to it
i wanted them to be like
prove me wrong challenge my beliefs let
there be some actual
discourse that's why i'm saying it i'm
not saying they didn't have a grasp of
the human language
or that they don't write in a specific
format i'm saying their argument wasn't
strong because there was no empirical
evidence go ahead awesome sorry i yeah i
i don't disagree
i um for me the funny thing is that the
case i
thought they were going to make is not
the one that they ended up making
because it reminded me of almost 20
years ago
i think it was time magazine
although i don't i honestly don't
remember it could have been any number
of magazines but i remember
when the lord of the rings films came
out
um and they were just this just
monumental success
i remember reading an article that
basically was saying
why do we love these movies so much
and their argument was the fellowship of
the ring
and the two towers and returned the king
had all come out
right on the heels of september 11th
when
the clarity of morality was shaken
horrendously
and that that the escapism represented
by
good old-fashioned good versus evil
where it was no longer about you know is
frodo good
seen through the right lens does sauron
have a
point that's worth considering like
these films completely
skewed that right and uh uh
in keeping with the source material and
they said the world the world got really
messy
uh because september 11th you know it
unified everyone but then very quickly
everyone said well you know
the u.s foreign policy has not exactly
uh sort of failed to
dare i say invite some kind of response
violent or or political or whatever and
it's just like very quickly
we were down this rabbit hole of going
yeah you know this this we really want
to make this good
versus evil but but um it's it's not so
clear-cut
uh even just on a skin-deep reading and
that these movies came along and offered
us this just this glorious escapism i
thought that was the angle they were
gonna take
that they were like because the world is
as
or more gray now than it was then and i
thought they were saying why on earth do
i want my games to be a reminder of how
[ __ ] difficult to navigate everything
is i was sure that's where they were
going to go
and it wasn't at all they actually went
the opposite i was actually amazed that
this sort of
secret ending of this article if you
make it all the way to the bottom
is to say uh it was actually
surprisingly ideological and
irrespective of where you land on their
comments they were basically saying you
know we live in a world where
where there really are right and wrong
uh arguments being made and like
you can't like you can you can say you
know somebody says black lives matter
another one replies
well you know all lives matter as just
an example that's not quite how they
phrase it in the article but they're
basically saying
you know one of these is right and one
is wrong and they're basically touting
that as their claim and i was like now
you see
that's where you might lose me because
i'm
inclined to agree with you but you do
have to back that up because
you this is gray actually like there are
counter arguments
they may not be convincing i may not be
convinced by them
many people may not be but they do exist
and you're basically
saying you know the world is actually
quite objective
and it's annoying that these games don't
reflect that that was my takeaway from
the article and i thought
well now that's the opposite claim i
thought you were going to be coming with
i was really sure that you were saying
you bemoan the lack of escapism uh that
they represent
and it didn't seem to be that so to me
it was austin it was you're the one who
suggested it
um and because i feel like we dove right
into this topic do you want to like
just a little briefly even though you
already have just explain what the
article is
because if we didn't actually do that
sure yeah well it was
it was and it was an opinion piece i
just pulled it up and actually to your
point
alana it actually does say opinion right
as a
as a banner at the top i didn't remember
that ki hoon
chan forgive my mispronunciation if it's
if it's coffee buddy
um it um games need to it's a polygon
article games need to return to black
and white morality and they and they use
um uh both bioshock infinite and the
last of us
as two of their [ __ ] dunk don baker
yeah trigger trigger
the their their case studies
and far cry too i was like well first of
all that could be there's there's two
other people at least that they've been
picking on and now giancarlo esposito
can be added to it but
would you not say here's where i kind of
um
what pinged me immediately i'm fine with
um someone having an opinion piece um
i feel like saying something games need
to do this
or as opposed to why games could benefit
by returning to black and white morality
does that copy does the article itself
say that because i i was i think
it's i think it might be a case of i
can't remember if the article made that
strong or not if that if the article
made that strong statement or
the headline right which is an editorial
choice again like i wonder
i can't remember if the body of the text
actually kind of goes as far as to say
this must be like this i think that the
headline is obviously
written to be decisive and interesting
and sorry
it says what i crave and what i think we
deserve a black and white game centered
around the concept of absolute objective
morality
um so it doesn't say they must be like
this and i do think
that's saying i won't right no games
need to return to black and white
morality
the headline that's the headline right
yes that's what i'm saying yeah but
headlines but the rights doesn't write
the headline yeah sorry that's a whole
thing i in some cases yeah headlines are
often really
very much in an opinion piece like this
is that an editor-in-chief or whatever
the
i'm i'm not usually a body of people you
pick a headline
i wake up to do that at like seven i did
it on the nintendo switch sales reports
which is crazy [ __ ]
um and then at nine everyone else jumps
in reads what i've written and we
brainstorm headlines
amongst about seven people until we pick
one that is going to traffic well
and then i edit the very start of the
script to make sure that it fits in line
with that headline and that's
a systemic problem it's not an
individual
it's a how yeah it's i mean it's that's
uh shades of grey troy
what shades of grey but he used to go
back to black and white
so austin's earlier point i do think
this like it's very interesting to this
this piece without referencing uh any
other philosophical pieces ends up
making an extremely
philosophical very hard stance which is
that there is objective morality which
is
a whole thing that i'm like yeah that's
like from from a
from a philosophy standpoint the idea of
objective morality is
um i feel like i needless to say there's
objective ethics
well that i mean if you want to get into
it that's one of those where
i don't think that that is considered
amongst philosophers a settled issue but
where i've personally landed on that and
i'm as with troy always subject to uh
being challenged and and revised but it
seems to me that objective reality or
objective well that as well but
objective
uh morality uh
objective morality um is
essentially non-existent but you can
make
objective uh there can be objective
moral um
like choices or or movements
if everybody agrees on the fundamental
goals
and so that in other words if we agree
on what basically morality helps us
choose
what is good better best you know on
down
uh and but we have to agree on what that
high point
is and so generally people do seem to
agree that
human well-being would represent the
shared goal
if we have a shared goal then
we can make a objective assessments
about whether such an action
moves us closer or further away from
that well-being many of which
may be subject to intense debate but
that there is potentially
movement along that that spectrum this
is the complicated like even
oh yeah right like a really complicated
conversation and
i mean for sure to to uh while i would
love to talk about philosophy this whole
time to just
at least address more of this this
article
um i inherently uh do disagree with it
um i don't disagree with the way it's
written
um i i agree that like for the way if i
had written this
i would have tried to probably reach out
to either
studios to even ask how they approach
morality to philosophers to discuss this
kind of thing that is probably more
along the lines of what i would have
done but
i don't mind reaching reading a very
strongly worded article
uh but i also don't agree because you
know uh
austin you bring up the 911 lord of the
rings thing
the idea that uh sometimes you need
something comforting to
uh save you from the real world the
things that immerse me the most are the
things i'm thinking about for the
longest amount of time
you know like when i read watchmen
that's
very gray and that was something that i
found
very immersive because it wasn't black
and white which means i have to think
about it more
at all times and it's sure it can make
you think about real world politics and
make parallels that you'd prefer to
avoid which
is probably inherently unhealthy in its
own right but that's a whole other thing
but
i think things that are gray are
generally more immersive because you are
having to assess things constantly
rather than having
a literal black and white moral well
here's what i
here's what i i'm sorry it's where i i
think that
they failed to differentiate at least
two types of narrative experiences
it kind of equivocates as though all
games fit under the same umbrella
and in my mind there's at least two
different categories
here there's like the allegory you know
like greek mythology or something
that's where your black and white
morality starts to be
more useful because it's it's a story
that is used in an intentionally sort of
abstract unrealistic way
from which to to gain a vantage point
you know to say oh here's where i am
relative to this kind of
paragon of enlightenment or whatever but
it's it's it's
it's intentionally unrealistic and yes
there are lots of games of good versus
evil that to me are essentially they're
like mythic
tales in that way whereas something
that's trying to get into the meat of
life i mean
would they make the same argument that
like hemingway would do better to be
more black and white
and and and uh you know
countless endless authors and literature
and film throughout
history because they're they're not
they're not going for that abstract
unrealistic allegory type fiction
they're going for something that's
supposed to feel very true to life and
to me that was
the real coup of of the last and
bioshock infinite for all of its
amazing unrealism uh the notion of like
discovering
it's the same as the dark knight right
like discovering when you are the thing
that
you are supposedly trying to destroy
spoiler for bioshock infinite eight
years in the making
um and uh so i to me it's like
that's great i i can't i can't imagine
finding that that's somehow taking away
from the art of games i'm like games
didn't have this
for the longest time and now that we're
starting to get
really really substantive explorations
of gray morality it's like
whoa tap the brakes on that i just i i
found it a baffling take
um i think it's also very akin to
someone saying game's going to return to
platformers
games need to return to it to be more 3d
platformers bring them back
but not even i mean i'm saying it's like
one
game should just be this this is what
games should be it's like who says who
do
you mean exactly isn't that isn't that
like what the crux of the absolutely
ludicrous gamergate type arguments were
of like well you're ruining what my
perception of games supposed to have
been i need
i need my you know my brusque
emotionless men
and super sexualized women and don't
[ __ ] with my it's like
but not only that but it's awesome since
when are you in charge
none of that but what you said austin is
like why can't we have both
why can't you just just be broad it
doesn't need to
funnel back down into this it can be all
of it you can have your
2d side scrollers you can have your
beat-em-ups you can have your open-world
games you can have your racing games you
could have your linear games you could
have all these things that's the beauty
of this
is that it doesn't have to be as as
we've argued before
there is no perfect model this is
something that
is kind of an anomalous
blob it's like it's it's too you suit to
taste
you know thousands of games release a
day that doesn't apply to other
industries largely and i think one of my
most passionate video game takes is that
i want
uh more games that are less focused on
being cinematic and more focused on
exploring gameplay creativity
and that's like a take that i'm like use
the medium of video games to tell
stories ways that video games only can
rather than giving me cutscene walk
cutscene walk
however do movies right but i don't want
to get rid of the last of us which is
super cinematic i still want that to
exist
i also want ghost sushima to exist which
does plenty of walks cinematic walk
cinematic it's just that i want
also the other things right but i also
think sorry mike i love you i feel like
you have something you want to say and i
i
we continually keep cutting you off but
i it's cool no i'm i've i've got
so many things to say but i'm just like
you guys can't remember
i'm going to be honest yourself
[Laughter]
i i feel like what games do have the
benefit of doing is there are games that
go
we want to make our games more cinematic
and
that is where you will fail as opposed
to going here's what i'm going to do
i want to create a good game that uses
cinematic as an element that uses
immersive gameplay as an element that
uses emerging gameplay as an element
that uses good design as an element
and that's what gives you this great
experience as opposed to going if you
want a good game you have to have
cinematics
and that's what i don't agree with i
think the best stories that have come
out
have been the emergent ones the ones
that did you know that if you did this
this will happen
and a lot of times it's the the bugs
it's the breaks it's if
if you do if you stand here at this
exact time and you do this one thing you
could see a horse fly and red dead
redemption you know it's it's stuff like
that
so i i don't agree with um good
big cinematics equal good game i think
you can actually get bogged down in that
yeah i think it's a triple a problem
that they they can get stuck with but
generally like in complete agreement
more variety of video games equals good
including in storytelling where i feel
like the industry
can often be samey um and i think that
it's been awesome to see that branch
out in aaa uh the last of us part two i
always think and i mean you might be
able to speak to it troy
was always going to be controversial
leaks are not i think what happens in
that game some people were always going
to hate it
and that's such a big risk for a triple
a studio to take when you could have
made another story where
uh you try to place joel as the hero and
have people play alongside
you know the white dude on the cover
again and like keep doing the things you
know will work but they didn't
do that they took a massive risk the
abbey switch is a massive
risk uh and i would prefer that whether
people
at large like it or not then for things
to always be the same
that's the beauty of it is that what
people loved about the last of us
is that it it posited the question wait
a minute what is a hero
is joel a hero um or is he the villain
you know it's like we said about the
dark knight so i just and i i can't
fathom
thinking that's bad uh like that that's
somehow
that that somehow because i think part
of the claim of the article was that
it's sort of taking it's it's
distracting us
into thinking that people who are wrong
in the real world
have sort of meet on the bones of their
evil beliefs and they use like white
supremacy and things like that
as as the argument and i'm like but
like to the extent that though to the
extent that any of that
is gray it's demonstrably gray and to
the extent that any of its evil it is
demonstrably evil
like like how does eliminating the
conversation get us closer to
understanding that and comprehending
that like you know what i mean if
if if if things are considered above
discussion or below discussion i guess
um then how do we actually
learn from them and to me it's it was it
was it was a take that i thought was
it was it's like i sympathize with their
idea they're basically they're basically
coming at it from the angle of
games can be a powerful way to help
shape the world and it can help shape
people's thinking
and if we make them too gray then some
of the really horrible [ __ ]
in this world will sort of use the same
gray language to
be able to slip pie and and be allowed
to coexist
and i and and and my
response to that is is you know i think
you should have a higher opinion of
people's ability to learn into
spot evil where it is instead of saying
no no no we should be taught things are
black and white and that that way we can
use this language of good and evil to
point at the
white supremacists and say look no it's
just evil no no point of view
no white supremacists are bad yeah it's
like we can actually
unpack why that's bad like it that
doesn't have to just be
treated as black and white it can be we
can say like
why have the fear that you might be so
wrong that you should just
try to make it uh uh bulletproof to any
discussion like
it would have been a bit uncomfortable
if wolfenstein were like
but have you considered the nazis
perspective i would have been like i
don't
i don't know that i want to do this at
all i'm okay with not hearing the nazis
without wolfenstein
i'm all right with that so like but but
i do also what about
no russian oh no no russian's like one
of my favorite levels ever like
but how is that different basically from
what you're saying suppose yeah i mean
i guess the difference is literal nazis
i don't know but like i feel like part
of the the
the interesting thing to expand on here
is people who watch movies that are
marley gray
that's a specific audience video games
generally people who are
big gamers are going to play virtually
every triple a release or a lot of them
uh in a year like it doesn't matter if
it's morally gray or the story is there
or not so you could
very easily have a nazi playing
uh a game that's morally gray and if
their point is like well we should be
teaching lessons because the audience is
so broad like again i also get that
while simultaneously disagreeing with
with the ultimate point um
it's also just a lot of pressure to put
on our writing team you must teach the
lessons to the world that are
objectively good
is such uh an impossible task
you can't be done well plus that's what
i i also don't know that i think that
that's even a worthy goal like a
like they you know they always say
writers you know write what you know
um and so it's it's like
write your thoughts or your take uh on
these things you know like
i don't think neil and and what's what's
her name
ally gross hallie like i don't think
they
they told their the story that they
wanted to tell
i think that's that is their only
responsibility and they did that
immaculately in my opinion
factually objectively i also like really
appreciate about
the loss of his pot too that i still
don't know the answers to how i feel
about some things
when i finished that game i was like
mike i don't know what i can i
spoil i shouldn't it's fine you can if
you've been spoiled if you're okay with
the audience having support like
honestly like
maybe i just should yeah basically i was
just like i don't know what i want this
character to do and i don't know what
this character should have done and i
still don't know
uh you know when we were when we were at
to that exact point
it like as a as a as a kind of
variation on that point my when we were
working on journey
i remember actually going all the way
back to flow genova
chen the co-founder of that game company
his
whole mo was i want to make mature
content and he said to be clear
mature doesn't mean like higher polygon
count tits and ass or
explosions or saying [ __ ] true he goes
mature content
would be something like if you play it
at age 20 and then again at age 30
it will reveal different things to you
because you're in a different chapter in
your life
and then again at 40 or if you play it
before you have kids and after you have
kids or before you got married and after
you got married all that kind of thing
as you evolve it it reveals more to you
because in many ways it's more of a
mirror than it is just this
this plate offering up something and i
that really
like resonated deeply with me and that
to me that's the essence of what those
gray moral tales are all about
because your answer to abby and ellie
and whatnot today
might be totally different ten years
from now i mean mike i feel like you're
kind of the living embodiment of that
where
your reaction to the game is probably
nothing like what you would have felt 10
years ago like you've had a very
i mean i had that with a visceral
reaction when i played the first last of
us like
definitely i played a different game
when i replayed it like i definitely
reacted to that game very differently
years on just in a different place in
life
will you yeah i feel like right now
you're like
you're like for anyone who ever watches
shark tank where mark cuban
often just sits there and doesn't speak
for long periods and then just comes in
and goes i'll make you deal if you say
yes right now
yeah i'm waiting i'm waiting they don't
they don't most nervous so i'm like
what's he gonna say
i know yeah yeah so first of all
wolfenstein no
my stuff like is very different to what
i think you guys are reacting to like
first of all i definitely like disagree
on some of what like you're saying in
terms of i i do
i do believe in certain moral
absolutes like i think there's but i
don't think it matters to this argument
particularly like whether or not where
you stand on that i think the the
biggest kind of
challenge i oh and the other thing sorry
one thing i would say which i did i
didn't interrupt to say was um
another uh trilogy did very well from
releasing a couple of years after the
vietnam war
uh for the exact same reason you could
argue uh with star wars
yeah we did it um we got our
affirmations so yeah star wars is
exactly the same
argument was made at the time that that
was the reason that star wars doesn't
pull on vietnam
imagery but does pull heavily on second
world war imagery was that it provided a
much more straightforward war
where there were very obvious goodies
and valleys as well as the vietnamese
war obviously was
not viewed that way in america um no the
the the main issue i had with the
articles i think it conflates a bunch of
different criticisms and turns tries to
meld them into one's one simultaneous
argument i think there's
lots of good points in there and lots of
things i would agree with but by
combining them into this whole gray
versus black and white i think that's
the wrong uh
way of categorizing i think there's an
absolutely valid criticism of bioshock
infinite
in where it places its ethical argument
i disagree with the writing team of
bioshock infinite in terms of their read
of the ethics of that situation and
what's right and wrong in that world
but i know what they think i know i know
okay their stance was i can react to
their stance or i can react to the
stance as presented right they might be
they might have failed in writing and
accidentally said the wrong thing which
we've all done
but i disagree with their take similarly
when i play lossless 2
i fundamentally i think disagree with
um the perspective presented in the
writing of that about who humans are and
what we are as people
i have a different opinion i'm not
saying i'm right or wrong but i i
i bounced off that game i think to an
extent because i
i i differed but again a statement was
made
that's not the same thing as making a
a black and white piece i think all
narrative you mentioned watchmen as
a as a as a book which is has lots of
grayness in it
sure but i [ __ ] know what alan moore
thinks about everything based on that
book right
he makes statements try not to think
about when alan
thinks these days but he has an opinion
right he's presenting a perspective and
his
you could say it's moral but you don't
necessarily even need to take it that
far you can see his view of the world
through the writing i think
often one thing we really often fall
into the trap of
is conflating um someone's politic
someone's
uh someone's statement they're trying to
make with their work with the
uh with the protagonist of the story and
we say oh well
the characters in this story are shades
of grey so therefore this is this work
is
is grey in its morality last of us has
an opinion about humans
and about what humans should be it poses
questions but it does actually also
answer them because it's a story on some
extent there's obviously
vagueness and i'm not playing the end of
last week's two last of us one has a
moral stance it has an opinion on what
joel should do
and what that situation should be but it
has to because otherwise it wouldn't
end um similarly like i mean
the you mentioned um oh what did you
mention um tolkien
uh like tolkien out of perspective lord
of the rings is
filled with and you know a guy in the
50s
who's just been through a war and who
has
some not very advanced opinions about
different ethnicities around the world
like that stuff is in there i'm not
saying that tolkien's a terrible human
being or we should hold into modern
standards but
he had a stance he had opinions he had
morals and ethics and
views that come through in his work even
bloody
game of thrones right like which is
cited in the article is like something
that's shades of grey
again it's a the books and and i think
to a lesser extent the tv shows they're
not as well written as the books
but the books have an opinion about
humans and a statement they want to make
about how we treat each other about
how history works how history repeats
often and
and the way and the the choices it makes
about which parts of
specifically english history it chooses
to call on with those with those stories
i guess my point is i think the piece
combines the idea of morally ambiguous
characters
with morally ambiguous stories and i
don't think those two
i think you can make a morally ambiguous
story with an absolutely black and white
character
and i think you can make a morally
ambiguous character in a very black and
white story and i think
a lot of the confusion i found reading
it most stories
have that trade-off because that's how
you explore that if you're making
something it would be very hard to write
a morally ambiguous story i think if i
look at any of the
books i've ever written they would
because they're written i
intentionally have my point yeah
even even things like um and you can
often find that later right like even an
author who you're like oh this author
is you know publicly stated as being uh
there's
been several cases throughout history
it's been a very big one recently but
there's several cases throughout history
where
an author has written a very popular
work has had one
presumed political stance and then later
in their life has been
you know has decided out themselves as
having a wildly different political
perspective
and immediately people go back to the
works they've produced and go oh yeah it
was always there like that that
that stance was always built into their
work and some of that is raw shack right
some of that is finding what you want to
see in works
but a lot of it isn't i think we can't
help but create works with an opinion
i don't even if we're trying really hard
not to i think what's interesting with
games this is my final thing and i was
shut up
games never by their nature a
possibility space so there has to be an
element of choice even if it's even if
it's even a very linear story there's
still always going to be
a debate in any there's a debate in any
story because otherwise you'd have no
conflict and therefore no story
you'll be a sermon rather than a story
but even in games you
they are possibility spaces and i think
that's inevitably technically going to
increase as time goes on as we end up
with stories that are more
more emergent more built around systems
you are still going to get that stuff in
and and
but i still think my point stands
because if you look at simcity
i sorry this is just verbal super now i
apologize if you look at sim city right
where is sim city yeah oh well
so simcity is obviously emergent there's
no story there's no characters
except the dude who gives you advice
when you're working or whatever
but simcity is based specifically on a
book on city zoning
that was published under a specific
government in america and has
a definite political stance on how
cities should be organized i didn't
know systems it's totally true and and i
i think it's still it's
you know it's pretty middle of the road
politically but like it's a political
opinion
the systems of sim city are hard coded
with expectations about how cities
should work
in an ideal situation if there's a win
state in a game it has an opinion on
what you should do in a situation right
if the win state of the game is to kill
everyone in the room the game is making
a statement about
killing people right like we can't help
but do this
so that that for me it's it's a very
it's kind of an argument that doesn't
make any sense to me because
inevitably games will be grey and
inevitably
in terms of the authors making them they
will be black and white the author will
have a stance and opinion
and neither of those two things can
really be removed so there's always
going to be this dichotomy and i think
that's maybe what the writer is reacting
to is that
there is a messiness between those two
things and that's what makes great
stories that's what's interesting
and now i'll show you i'm curious sorry
i was just spoiling all that up as we
went i didn't want to blow into the dude
yeah well there's something i want to
specifically tug at in what you just
said mike
you said is it the start
when you said that you found yourself
bumping bumping up against
the claims the the intrinsic
claims about humanity in the writing of
the last of us
two specifically um
um what was that and what what was i
reacting to
well not it doesn't actually it doesn't
even matter my point is
isn't that in and of itself laudable
then
because doesn't that mean that by virtue
of you having something to react to and
go
now i don't think things are like that
at all
that's troy's thing about like the
conversation at the water cooler the
next day
yeah i'm disagreeing with the writer and
that's okay and and i think that's
something that gets conflated into that
article
it's not even that it's okay i i think
it's actually better than operation
because it means that
yeah the the writing the writing that
fails is the writing that makes its
stance so murky and unclear that you
don't even know
what to take away from it and it's like
i would much rather disagree
than not know yeah another and that's
the that's why i think bioshock
infinites a really odd kind of choice of
example in that piece is because
bioshock infinite definitely does have a
view
and it's the view that stated like the
the treaties of bioshock infinite
whether intentional or not
is potential it's that that
there's an equality between the two
sides of of that political debate
that's by using the artistry they are by
choosing the
racial like it's it's it's in the text
like you definitely can make that
reading
the you know the who comstock is and how
that's presented
who the rebels are and how that's
presented and all of the iconography
that's used in that story that puts in a
very specific time period in american
history
there is a statement being made whether
intentional or not
and yeah that's something that i think
and god knows there was at the time
right we can all debate whether we agree
or disagree with that or like or dislike
that
but to to claim the bioshock infinite is
a shades of grey game is really odd to
me
what but crucially there though that's
where
it gets interesting because it was true
well
it was maybe trying to be and that's the
interesting thing right is that that's a
reaction to
you could make an argument that the
politics presented there are
shades of grey argument there's good and
bad people on both sides it's kind of
the
there's a that's part of the political
message of that game
that's different though to criticizing a
story for being gray in its telling
right that's so there's a different
again it feels like five different
criticisms or arguments about game
creation kind of merged into one and i
i think where those i get the
distinction the lab gets messy
you know so that was where i know it
fell over and to be clear on the last of
us two criticism because there'll be 50
comments
specifically my criticism because i've
not finished it so i have no opinion
about it as an overall thing
it's more just generally the zombie
genre having been through a period in
history where
we had a horrible worldwide event happen
and a large proportional population
chose to use that as an opportunity for
reflection and for improvement
my perspective on how we would react to
an actual zombie apocalypse
is different than it was two years ago
like it feels like people might be
better than we assume
on a lot of levels and that that's my
that we could do a podcast on that right
but that's that's where my
that's why last of us two came a weird
time for me it felt like a different i
had a different view on humanity than i
did before
um anyway sorry i'm dominating now i
apologize that's fine no
i just want to very quickly have any of
you read um the ones who
walk away from omalas no it's my
favorite short story ever written and
i'm just i don't even need to get into
it i just want to give it a shout that
you can read it online
it takes a couple of minutes um and it
is
something that like you i've seen people
argue before i mean it's really old it's
from like the 1970s i mean that's not
that all really
the great stupid things but um i've seen
people online argue that it is morally
ambiguous and it's up to you
to decide based on the ending of that
short story how you feel about
it morally and the conversation that
it's trying to have but i feel like it
is also still to
your point mike very clear when a writer
has an opinion even if they aren't
trying to force it on you and i think
again if i think about everything i've
ever written i
i feel like i don't even have a say in
sharing my opinion really i find that
very difficult
i have not thought about it i love it
when you i can write characters that
aren't like me
yeah but not points that i don't
resonate with
the characters are they're the they're
the the dolls the puppets we're using
but the story and the moral framework of
what we've built it's it's funny when i
go back because i don't play my own
games until like
five or six years after release and i go
back and play them and i'm like
i'm like oh i had an opinion about that
but i didn't necessarily
i hadn't put that into words yet but
it's right there in the text like i was
yeah it's it's an interesting thing like
yeah reading your own writing years
later and going oh i was
i was i hadn't really thought
yeah i also think like talking about you
know games being morally gray
um i mean
spec ops is like one of my favorite
games in terms of the way that it's
written and i don't know that it's
marley gray i feel like it is taking a
stance but it's still challenging
in a way that i also feel like the last
of us part two
is challenging and i i do prefer to be
challenged
to think about characters in the way
that it presents and
i even like that in choice based games
where you know you are
you're a paragon or a renegade but some
of those decisions actually are
complicated and i feel like bioshock did
do a very good job of
all of the various morality-based choice
rpgs um
where often i don't know what the right
call is i don't know
if uh a certain species should die or or
rather should uh have their reproduction
abilities limited because if they don't
they will overrun absolutely everyone
because their growth rate is so sporadic
and they're so aggressive like i just
like
that stuff is like i know where i rely
on that don't kill rex
but it gets complicated like like like
i don't wait i know you went into that
explaining like it as a morally i think
it's but like
even that like right like how that plays
into like
stereotypical racist arguments is really
interesting right like there's
i think is why my perspective is the way
that it is is like if i apply this to
the real world
we're not killing them come on but you
know it's still something that it makes
you think about
uh in a way where they are still making
a point i think i don't think it's like
bioware i don't think unnecessarily like
yes you should kill this entire species
that's what we think you should do but
they're like but
here are the downsides to doing here
here's why this is
and i appreciate that like giving me
something to think about i think is more
interesting than having a game that's
black and white in a lot of cases and
i'm
trying to think about like one of my
favorite black and white games the first
one that comes to mind
is fable oh really nice
good game nice um but that's only
because it's stupid in its decisions
like if i eat a live chicken i will grow
horns
into it but i feel like i don't know
what what's the best black and white
story in video games
i think spec ops might be the best
yeah limbo i think specs is black and
white i think spec
has a very strong and specific opinion
about the subject it's talking about
i don't think spec ops invites you to to
have the opposite opinion to spare no it
doesn't you're right it doesn't go
maybe you're okay with genocide it is
very much saying thing is bad it's just
the way that it eases you into thing
being bad is that it doesn't initially
seem to be so and i think there's room
for yeah for
all kinds of it yeah for me i think you
know probably unsurprisingly because i'm
such a broken record on it but grim
fandango
is uh there's no moral ambiguity really
presented in that game it's like it's
it's a classic kind of film noir
um you know intrigue where you've you've
got the bad guys doing
clearly bad things taking advantage of i
mean
in fact it's it's it's sort of
ludicrously black and white because the
whole premise what sets it off is that
your character of manny
discovers that this girl um
mercedes kolomar who's supposed to be
like a saint you know she
she worked in like a mission taking care
of the poor
at the expense of her own living and et
cetera et cetera et cetera said it's
just like
pile on everything that you can to make
someone seemingly just the absolute
epitome of perfection
and then when she gets to the afterlife
they tell her you have the worst
possible
uh four-year journey to to the beyond to
the permanent beyond and that's the
whole
jumping-off point of the game is to say
well what the hell
happened in the system that made you who
should be given the
expressed ticket on the number nine uh
uh to bypass all this crap um and so
that's where you discover all the
corruption of the the damned evil souls
trying to figure out how to steal
people's
uh sort of golden tickets and it's like
that's clearly there's no
uh but that's where i that's where to me
it's like
that's that's why i was harping on the
equivocation kind of like the point
you're making mike
at the about the article where it made
it sound like all stories have the same
narrative burden
and that the writers of themselves are
assuming all the same narrative burdens
and i'm like i don't think tim schafer
wanted to make a game that has us
wrestling with the difference between
good and bad
uh he wanted to tell a very different
story that had different goals
um and dealt with different tropes and
all of that and so it's like
to me you know holding it up because if
someone
had the opposite take and they say all
this black and white
is taking away from learning about real
life you know they could hold up
fandango as like here's a game that just
doesn't get it and it's like what a
superficial take
on life you know maybe for the good
place myself but yeah
i i take that same thing a good place
good even good place
does that show get good because
how far did you watch it how far did you
do oh great
that's i couldn't even make it to the
end of season one because i was like
this is so
cool this is so crazy you
have to make it to the end of season one
no no one say anything
okay and do not read the comments austin
please watch to the end of season one
yeah i do because i heard everybody
talking about how the series finale was
like one of those that should go down in
history as
head dances ted danson gets to have
troy you are
watch series one and then i promise you
you're gonna immediately wanna watch
series two
you are nice you are your reaction to
the show is exactly what the people
making it want you to be feeling right
now
i was i was out and then i was like oh
[ __ ]
now i see what they're doing all right
all right i i i
i really i i was sure that that was the
case
i was like everybody people whose
taste i align with loves it like
ravenously love this
and i'm sitting here normally it's going
to be your favorite why like genuinely
austin knowing you as well as i do it's
going to be your favorite show
yeah yeah challenge accepted
here's a question for you just based on
something that i think it was
i came right it was either austin or
mike said this is it incumbent upon
games or is it is it the function of
games to instill
morality or to discuss it
i think they can't help but do the first
i think i think the first is a given
they can't depend on still it i think we
cannot i think we cannot help but make
work which has a political
uh or or any stance like we can't help
but no no that's not
something yeah but that's not it oh you
mean like an active
preacher kind of yeah are we here too
rod sterling has a great thing about
this where he he discussed this he said
that you know i will and
alana you said this i will um
invariably and inevitably
um present it will always be my words
coming out of my character's mouth
in some form um
[Music]
my i'm writing from my view otherwise
what am i doing
um the difference though is and like you
said mike it's not a point to
these aren't sermons um although i think
there can be
you can absolutely do that which which
is there's nothing written
yes it's just a digest but but i think
that i i
i just i'm questioning is it the purpose
or the function
or responsibility of games
specifically to instill morality
or is it to just simply discuss it and
and leave the
audience to i think it's i think it's
like i think it's oh uh i think i'm
going to take it i'm going to take it
i'm going to be pushing i'm not going
for sure
it's cool because i feel bad for last
time um i think it's i think it's up to
the developer whether they do the first
or the second or neither
but i also think it's incredibly fair
for the audience and you know
professional audience or or people who
just play our games
like to to ask for what they want and to
say i would like more of this kind of
stuff
which i think is all this article
ultimately is doing is even though i
disagree with parts of it i think it is
it's a it's a reasonable request of like
i would like more stuff that does
this stuff i like and less of this stuff
i don't basically i think all parties in
it should do exactly what they want and
we'll all keep arguing with each other
about whether our stuff is good or not
i think i'm vehemently against the idea
that games
should do anything if you don't want to
tell a story at all
and you just want me to be jumping
across platforms i will do that i've
been playing a lot of fall guys
ain't got no morals there i don't think
games should have to do anything the one
thing that i will champion that i would
put pressure on virtually every studio
for is accessibility options so that the
disabled community can play more games
that is one thing that i feel very
strongly about is trying to make your
games more accessible to more people
where possible um
do you see even ryan reynolds has joined
that that discussion
as of a few hours ago really steve got
ryan reynolds to do like a video
like for ablegamers it's amazing oh wow
that's so cool yeah
that's awesome um i miss that but yeah
when it comes to telling a story i don't
think you should have to insulin
anything you should just discuss
whatever you want to or really the best
stories are the ones that are
passionately written
so especially like in the case of the
last was part two which i feel like one
of the most controversial video game
narratives ever written at this point
just tell the story that you want to
that's what i want you to do
i don't want you to change any of it and
what it's worth
i i think actually i don't know that i
think that there's a difference between
the two
choices that you offered up troy because
when you say is it incumbent to instill
morals versus uh instill discourse about
morals to me
the first one only even makes sense if
we all agree on those morals
so it it automatically punts to the
second one instantly
uh right so if i don't agree with what
you're saying
if there was a game that was like um
great uh it's creation
right okay yeah yeah right i was waiting
for the quote that was gonna be taken
out of context
to be able to say here here's a game
about creationism
or whatever we would have to agree that
that's a fact first in order for us to
i can instill or in any kind of like
judeo-christian
uh you know um
you can se i'm trying to find something
that is clearly so black and white and
this is why i disagree with the articles
to me there's just not
there's not one even if you say you can
say it is wrong to kill
like okay but
who is it you know yeah exactly you can
punt to the hitler
situational right and then well then i
would kill hitler's like but wait a
minute
you're doing the same thing so
hold on a second so then it becomes this
whole argument that you break down
it's like any time you go to hitler it's
just like dropping the nuke yeah
i mean there are some things that like
no never mind it doesn't work what i was
gonna say doesn't work
yeah to me to me the whole notion of
instilling morals is
the best that i could come up with there
is that it would be
um you're instilling your
you're trying to instill your moral
perspective
but that's actually to me you can do it
passively and not so overtly and be able
to go this is what i think what do you
think and i think that games that
doesn't have to do that but but then
isn't that the second
the second of your two categories like
to me they are not differentiable they
are the same because i think that games
that that try to do the first
that's where they fail that's when it
feels preachy and that's what it feels
like
but doesn't doesn't that statement make
you as bad as the criticisms you're
leveling up kind of this piece like both
should exist right there should be games
that are massively preachy
you might not like them i think it's
cool to have a range exactly
yeah that's my point it's like go for it
but that doesn't mean they should do
this or they shouldn't do that
that's that's why i think if you want a
game that's kind of like
good guys wear black bad guys were or
you know good guys wear white bad guys
wear black and that's just
i want to easily identify who am i
killing who am i shooting who am i
racing who am i beating up who am i
fine bad guys are red crystals and
you've got to kill them
yeah i mean you never asked why it
actually that game actually does get
like weirdly like in the weeds
that game does have a story and an
ethical that actually does is that
i love it but it also is able to kind of
escape past that
by going it's all a simulation you're
interested i think that's where the
simulation
i think that the the differentiation
then is is what you're saying is more
like
a game that is shining a light on the
fact that these are discussable
versus a game that just presents it as
if this is just a fact
that's that's really i think what you're
getting at if i if i could be so
bold is to restate it that because that
because yeah that's where i think the
last of us
is is not making a sort of top-down
objective moral assessment it's it's
in fact that i guess would be the
criticism of it is is
which i don't agree with is i loved this
about it but it is making the claim
look how gray this [ __ ] is as opposed to
look how good or evil but isn't that
almost a black and white stance
it's presenting it's the bioshock
infinite thing it is very specifically
presenting
that as a statement that the the the
humanity
and that and that is the argument of the
article is to say it's wrong to present
some things as black and white
it also as gray which aren't between
but it oscillates between criticizing
that versus criticizing
there are points where where it
critiques someone for presenting a black
and white argument a great it goes
between the two which is
where i think argue the argument kind of
falls down a little bit um
i sorry go ahead go on no no no
no it's not so cool though you know
what's really really
awesome about my job
well you always worry about your job
there's no political aspect
what's awesome about my job is that i
get to spend a couple hours
uh hashing this out with you guys
and then completely set it aside because
music doesn't seem to care one way or
the other
there is no way to work politics into
music is what you're saying right
there's actually it helps it helps
inform it though like you can you can
easily change a character by changing
the music
that's underscoring that no i mean
actually that that that is that is
intentional irony because
especially if you look at the modern
classical world there is
constant contentious debate about how
subversively politicized it has been
literally
everything is even google because it was
programmed by humans is unintentionally
political to the extent that there are
studies where if you look up
professional hairstyle for women
none of them are women with black hair
like it's because things are made by
humans
even programs are always going to be
inherently political if you look up
unprofessional hairstyles you will get
black women
and that's the only icp is gonna say
i've evolved past you
you no longer suit me think about those
two [ __ ] google ai who developed a
language to communicate with each other
because it was more efficient than
english and they had to shut them down
they were like we can't have any of this
[ __ ] right there that was the microsoft
one developed racism
it's but yeah it's we're all that's i
think that's and that's why my point is
like
we're all anyone who makes a creative
work is going to
infuse politics into that by by nature
of
their experience you can't help you make
everything as is a political choice
the question is to what extent do you do
that with intent
and how successful are you in conveying
the point you're trying to convey if
you're trying to convey it
and those are the only metrics i think
that you can put on top of your
political science
and that's what's going on with the
broad spectrum of that yeah of course we
should i want to see all
grades of that yeah for sure but you
must also
truly define what politics means
it's also hard everything right no it's
not politics and like look at the greek
definition
of the all right of the word we've done
stuff
centroid as a society
since the greeks have we man
i prefer that version of [ __ ]
democracy let me tell you that
you can you can read stuff from from
greeks and romans
and it's you could read it as if it's a
modern day newspaper it's like the same
[ __ ]
politics is the view of the vox popular
it is the view of the people
it's not about politicians politicians
are a byproduct
but you have political stances politics
is the set
of activities that are associated with
making decisions in groups or other
forms of power relations between
individuals such as the distribution of
resources or status
has nothing to do possible to make a
video game with double cards
but no but it's still it's politics
regardless of that
and you're and if you're making a game
what are games about right games
are about interactions between people
and the movement of resources between
groups it's
like you can't the definition you just
gave of politics like that's
the stuff that games are about because
they're about actions and interactions
so therefore anything every game is
political that's basically my entire
[ __ ]
every game is political every
conversation is political every movie is
political every book is political
everything because it's the discussion
of ideas like you said between two
groups even if it's a one-sided
conversation
it is me as a writer fiction or
non-fiction that are conveying my
perspective and my beliefs
trying to either essay and and prove my
point like this person did in the
article
that's all politics politics isn't bad
whenever someone says you never discuss
politics
and religion i'm like those are the only
two interesting things
why are we here and what the [ __ ] are we
doing it's true
i don't want to discuss yeah if anybody
says i don't want to discuss politics
and religion like we're never going to
have a comment what are we talking about
what are we talking about does it so
does that mean that you think
that when people make comments like
uh you know you're just in the midst of
a cup let's say that we were having a
conversation about something totally
else and then
we kind of sidelined into where we are
now and someone were to raise their hand
and say
guys can we just leave politics out of
it is it your assessment then that that
is essentially a fundamentally naive
uh person ask the only time that i think
that
that
request makes sense is if you are
talking about politicians and someone's
like can we not
talk about democrats or party leaders
right now in that case i would be like
okay sure that's fair you don't want to
talk about the current election
uh but i think yeah yeah can we not talk
about politics
yes in general doesn't make sense
i think a person who says not not
necessarily
i i think is it is it naive in the sense
of like
can i walk around on the earth but not
obey gravity
like you're basically saying it's so i
think i think when people say i don't
want to talk about politics they mean
they don't want to be challenged on the
politics they have
and i think absolutely there's a lot of
us who have the privilege of walking
through life
and i know privileges of loaded term as
well but we get to walk through life
not being challenged on our politics you
don't notice politics until you see
something you disagree with
yeah and there's no moral like balance
on that
good good point i i love that
i also believe that most people who say
i don't want to talk about politics
the conversation that is being had is
exposing their lack of conviction and
i'm not talking about lack of opinion
i'm talking about lack of conviction i'm
talking about lack of fundamentally
understanding their own arguments
tell me i think to be honest
most people don't know why they believe
what they believe they just don't know
oh that is that is true we but but i
think what you're saying in terms of
of of people should have the the the
courage of their convictions i guess to
a certain extent right that's
pretty much the point that that article
ends on i think on that like there's
i definitely agree with the end of that
article what i agree with the start of
that article like i think there's a lot
the idea of to take take an opinion
there are right and wrong answers on on
issues you
can we can argue about absolute moral
morality but like there are definitely
things that are right and things that
are wrong
and can we having the courage we can't
do that now but i guess i don't want to
get into that with you like
okay moral absolutes i believe in i'm
not saying moral absolutely
i'm saying there are good and bad things
but you said moral absolutes
i said i actually said i think we
re-round the tape
i said not talking about moral absolutes
but i do think there is i guess it's i
guess the two are related and
overlapping but yeah i i think to bring
this full circle
i am going to say in the same token of
being appreciative of video games that
explore all the different sides of this
and take hard stances and don't
i am actually glad to have articles like
this damn right
writers like this that spark these
discussions where same token they are
making a strong stance
um we all i think fundamentally disagree
with a lot of it but it sparked an
interesting conversation between
all of us for over an hour uh and is
very strongly written in a way that's
i still sparked thought um i like
disagreeing with things so i appreciate
that
evidence yeah that is the evidence that
it was it was a conversation worth
having is because like you said
67 minutes later we're still discussing
and we have to hard cut it off because
we could continue to do it
that to me is evidence in the same way
that a good game the best evidence of it
is the conversation that is found in its
wake
uh when you talk was like the last of us
i kept like talking to people and being
like the fact that you keep wanting to
talk to me about this
means it has sort of done what it wanted
kind of you're supposed to discuss it
you're supposed to feel strongly about
what's happening yes you do have to go
i'm not the hard out today i am the
heart out oh is this gonna become a
thing where like we have uh who's the
heart out today are we gonna
look at us guys almost never gonna be me
yeah awesome
it's not gonna be me because it's the
evening for me so i have no good
experience
to leave mike's getting drunk he's like
[ __ ] it
piano doing whatever he does get real
play us out austin can you play us can i
stim play yourself
play something
all right everybody we'll see you next
week how do you do that
play watch and listen